bonjour et bienvenue dans les coulisses
de la soirée électorale de radio canada
on est dans le studio où on va diffuser
cette soirée électorale y un peu de
fébrilité on est en train de se préparer
première chose que vous voyez c'est
l'écran avec lequel je vais m'amuser
lundi soir c'est l'écran des
circonscriptions la carte du québec
découpé en circonscriptions électorales
voyez juste à toucher avec le doigt je
peux par exemple on allait dans la
grande région de montréal laval l'île de
montréal la montérégie et la couronne
nord de montréal et tous à découper en
circonscription bien ce studio il est
quand même assez vaste il ya un écran
géant ici en arrière où on va diffuser
plusieurs cartes et où vous allez
pouvoir avoir une meilleure idée de ce
qui se passe pendant la soirée des
luttes chaude à suivre des candidats
élus des candidats défaits et l'envers
du décor c'est aussi toutes sortes de
spaghettis ici que vous verrez pas vous
allez voir maintenant mais vous ne
verrez pas pendant la soirée électorale
parce que c'est caché par le bureau
derrière lequel on va se trouver
je vous garantis que chacun des fils qui
est ici sert à quelque chose
il ya des gens qui sont là pour sa
patrie soit l'animateur de la soirée va
être ici
moi je vais être assez à droite et juste
à côté de patrice il va y avoir trois
analystes les meilleurs michel c o g
chantal hébert et michel david aussi et
vous voyez derrière moi là vu que pas
très soit moi et des trois analystes
on va avoir pour cette soirée électorale
on se donne rendez-vous donc lundi soir